in Jiu-Jitsu kaisen the Gojo zenin and K
clans were first introduced as the most
powerful families in the series besides
the fact that they each had money and
huge political influence what made the
three Clans interesting is that they're
one of the few things that remain
constant in the Jiu-Jitsu world that's
why it's amazing that in just 6 months
since Yuji at suen his finger the zenin
K and Goa families have now all been
completely crushed in one way or another
spoiler warning ahead but in today's
video I'll be explaining exactly how the
actions of kinjaku and sukuna led to the
ruin of the big three Clans and by the
end you'll understand how the series can
move on after Gojo's fight to the death
okay so starting off with the zenin clan
their downfall was probably the least
surprising out of the three considering
how explicitly it got foreshadowed in
the jjk movie that being said it's still
worth examining why the clown was
destroyed and it all traces back to
their traditional beliefs throughout the
manga we learned that the only thing the
zening care about is whether someone has
talent as a sorcerer and if that Talent
isn't there they just don't treat you
like a human being this backwards way of
thinking is why toi was given such a
hard time when he was young cuz the
family could never accept someone
without a single drop of cursed energy
what's ironic about this is that naoya
and ranen acknowledged that toi had the
strength to single-handedly wipe them
all out yet at the same time no one else
respected him since Heavenly restriction
wasn't the kind of power that they were
used to this thought process is exactly
what stopped the clan from progressing
since they curse techniques as being
everything even though we've seen
firsthand that there is more to it than
that for instance characters like Kimo
Mari Yugi and of course toi they've all
done insane things without needing to
activate a curse technique and if the
zenin had been open-minded about that
then this monster could have been part
of their ranks from day one instead they
fumbled it by abusing toi until he left
the clan which is what makes the Zen in
so different from the Gojo in jjk the
Gojo represent the more Progressive
faction in that satu was always willing
to disregard tradition and would accept
anyone as long as they had potential in
the process he created an army of Future
Special grade Sorcerers while at the
same time the zenin was stunting their
own growth because of their
shortsightedness and refusal to learn
from their own mistakes Mari ended up
leaving the clan in the same way toi did
and this is where their downfall
actually began as Mari progressed at
Jiu-Jitsu High the head of the zening
clan nowo used his influence to make her
life as difficult as possible this
included punishing her sister preventing
access to certain curse tools and making
sure Mari was ranked as a low grade four
even when her results were at least that
of a grade 2 however probably the most
Shameless thing they did came in chapter
148 where the zenin secretly planned to
kill meami Mari and Ma for their own
personal gain just before we get into
that though a quick word from today's
sponsor rage Shadow Legends if you live
on planet Earth it's very likely you've
heard of this game before but in the
past year there have been huge changes
you might not know about that's why I've
drafted in Professor death knight to
give you all a quick lesson on the
changes and according to him you're not
allowed to skip the Clause Professor
death knight here with a lesson about
live Arena the new PVP mode where you
can fight against other players in real
time sounds terrifying well so's going
to the dentist you should still do it
when you win matches you'll get live
Arena crests towards unlocking special
area bonuses or so I hear I'm too afraid
to try any of this out oh all right
class any questions yeah um so what
exactly is your plan to survive the live
Arena well everyone thinks I'll go in
fighting but nobody expects my charm my
best strength is The Gift of Gab so when
they try to attack I'll just be like
nice weather we're having eh nobody will
see it coming I hope you use this
knowledge you've gained here today about
live Arena to head off and do battle
live make this whole dead bones
Professor proud folks if you're a brand
new player all you have to do is use the
code J D skin to get stag knite who's an
epic Champion with a custom skin
designed by JonTron on top of that all
players whether you're old or new you
have the chance to get son Wukong also
known as The Monkey King and if you
didn't know this is a character from
Chinese mythology who was the
inspiration for Goku to get him in raid
all you have to do is log in for 7 days
in a row between now and the 23rd of
October so be sure to use the link in my
description or scan my QR code on screen
to download raid if you haven't already
if you click my link specifically you
get insane bonuses with this free
starter pack that includes Drake not
that Drake who's an epic Champion that
you get completely for free all right so
going back to the assassination attempt
like I said earlier the main thing this
Z didn't care about is Curse techniques
as a result when albo died he left the
family fortune to figura which was the
sensible Choice since it guaranteed that
the 10 Shadows technique would stay
within their immediate bloodline despite
that Sorcerers like janichi and oi
weren't prepared to accept the entire
family for going to toi's son given that
he'd been an outsider for most of his
life for that reason they plan to
execute fushiguro even though it would
weaken their own Clan but obviously they
couldn't just go and do it without some
kind of excuse this is where kinjaku
comes in as we're going to explain how
his actions led to the downfall of the
zenin clan and K Clan at the same time
one thing we need to realize about
Jiu-Jitsu headquarters is that most of
the people in charge are conservatives
who don't like change this is why the
regulations are so straight to against
literally anything they don't fully
understand or can't fully control hence
why Gojo hates them the way he does now
out of The Big Three Families the karma
were by far the most conservative
meaning they had the largest amount of
influence at Jiu-Jitsu HQ Kaku was fully
aware of this Dynamic which is why
around the time of the shabuya incident
he murdered the head of the K Clan and
took over their entire operation by
going this far he turned the carel clan
into his own personal puppets which
amazingly wasn't even the first first
time he tried to do this kinjaku then
increased his influence by eliminating
most of the hups who weren't under the K
Clan's control giving him almost total
power over the Lords of jiujitsu society
one of the laws that came into effect
after Gojo got sealed is that it would
become illegal for any sorcerer to try
and free him from the prison realm this
is what gave the zenin a perfect excuse
to kill megamy without any consequences
since they knew he'd be trying to free
godo along with the rest of Jiu-Jitsu
High additionally oi thought it would be
a great idea to get rid of Maki and Ma
as well since killing his own two
children would boost his credibility
with the higher-ups unfortunately for
him following Ma's death he wasn't
prepared for his other daughter to level
up the way she did and without much
effort Mari eradicated the entire zening
Clan what's funny about this is that on
that day she didn't actually go there
with the intention of doing this but it
was ogie's arrogance and heartlessness
that pushed her over the edge by the
time Mary was done the only people left
with Zen In Blood were were her and the
guy who wanted nothing to do with them
meaning that as an institution the zenin
clan is dead while the Carl Clan are
just puppets of konjaku by process of
elimination this left the Gojo Clan as
the only ones who weren't completely
ruined given that satu escaped from the
prison realm after Less Than 3 weeks of
course in typical gaygay fashion Gojo's
comeback didn't last for long with him
facing off against the king of curses
one month after he got out this is what
brings us to the main questions of the
video which is how big of an impact did
satu have as head of the clan and does
the family have a future now that he's
seemingly dead to answer that first
question I want you to imagine for a
second a world where Gojo acted just
like all the other higher-ups as head of
one of the big three families his
easiest option in life would have been
to just go with the flow and side with
the conservatives in fact in volume zero
he made a comment that it's possible for
him to end up like them if that had been
the case from the very beginning it's
guaranteed that Yuji UTA Panda and
principal Yaga all would have been
executed a long time ago megamy would
have been raised by the idiots in the
zening clan and students like Maki and
hakari would never have been supported
in the exact same way in the present
series though those students are now the
only hope there is of defeating suca and
Kaku and it's all because sat went out
of his way to lay the groundwork for a
new generation that could potentially
reach his level the end result of this
is the current situation where the true
Authority in the jiujitsu world doesn't
belong to the higher-ups since Gojo
students have proven time and time again
they don't really care about the rules
and regulations in fact in chapter 222
we see UT and inumaki walking into
jiujitsu headquarters and then in the
next chapter we get a room full of dead
hups heavily implying that these two
were the ones responsible when you
couple that with the fact that Mari
destroyed an entire Clan by herself the
new generation clearly doesn't follow
the old Power structures what that means
is that if at least some of Goo students
can survive till the end of the series
which is a big ask but if some of them
can survive then going forward J justu
Society can stop being held back by
tradition this would allow space for
either new Clans to emerge or for the
entire concept of Clans to become
irrelevant either way if satu really is
dead which is what it looks like as of
making this video then this reformed
Jiu-Jitsu society would be his impact as
the head of the Gojo family that being
said in terms of whether the Gojo Clan
has a future following his death the
answer to that largely depends on luck
the only reason satu was able to to get
away with the things he did is because
he was the first in hundreds of years to
have the six size and Limitless at the
same time if the godra clan get
incredibly lucky then another one might
be born this generation but even if that
was the case there are two problems
worth thinking about problem number one
is that just because a child is born
with these abilities it doesn't
guarantee they'll have a similar level
of talent satu was in a way uniquely
gifted in that he mastered how to do
reverse curse technique teleportation
consecutive domain expansions and Hollow
purple which is a power that was only
known to a few people in the Gojo family
personally I feel like that specific
line is something that gets overlooked
because if Hollow purple is something
that most people in the Gojo Clan didn't
know about then obviously it's not
something that had ever been frequently
used in the past remember in the present
day all the other clans already knew
about red blue and neutral Limitless but
Hollow purple was the one thing that was
just so rare that barely anyone was
aware of it until sasu used it this
shows us that he was clearly built
different to other Limitless users in
history especially considering how he
held his own against mahara and sua at
the same time whereas one of his
ancestors was killed by just mahaga by
itself also the manga goes out of its
way to paint a picture that he's a
natural genius so there's no guarantee
that any successor would be able to
reach that level moving on problem
number two relates to Tangen and the
possibility that another six eyes may
never appear again before I get into
this I'm going to mention that this is
just just a theory but there is some
evidence to suggest it might be possible
in chapter 145 we learned that Tangen
the star plasma vessel and the six eyes
are all connected by Destiny every 500
years the role of the six eyes seemed to
be protecting the star plasma vessel and
enabling the merger with Tangen to
happen according to Tangen toi destroyed
their Destinies when he killed Rico
ammani and this line can be interpreted
in a couple different ways one
interpretation is that the godra clan
has now effectively served its purpose
and now that Tangen has evolved into a
cursed Spirit there's no need for a six
size and star plasma vessel this by
itself doesn't mean that a six size will
never appear again but we have to wonder
how was this ability created in the
first place at first it's easy to assume
that these eyes are just a random
mutation in the goo Clan but if that's
the case why is there a specific rule
that two six size users can never exist
at the same time to me that sounds
nothing like a random mutation and more
like a binding contract that was made
within the Gojo Clan if it was genuinely
just a mutation then like any mutation
it should be able to be passed down to
multiple children in the same way as
things like hair color skin color and
other things like that the fact that the
eyes have this rule attached to them and
the fact that they also usually appear
when Tangen needs to merge it does make
it seem suspicious that there was some
kind of binding vow that was broken when
toi intervened let me know your opinion
on this in the comments down below but
all I'll say is that if the six size is
result of some kind of deal then there
is a chance even if it's only 1% that
the mutation never appears again in
history if that's the case then it
really would be the end of the Gojo Clan
and the likelihood is that they just
turn into more of a background family
similar to the inumaki of course another
way to look at this is that there have
been long periods of History before
where the clan has maintained relevance
even without a limitless user so they do
at least have a blueprint for how to
navigate through these type of
situations at a bare minimum the Gojo
still at least have the family fortune
so I don't know maybe it's time to start
investing in real estate or something
and just leave the fighting curses to
Yugi and whoever else regardless before
gay wraps everything up we surely have
to get the reaction of satar's relatives
to his death I mean it was kind of weird
that none of his family were involved in
trying to unseal him from the prison
realm so please G gay at the very least
show us a reaction to him being chopped
in half like that is the bare minimum it
would also be kind of nice to see who
the next head of the family is going to
be but I am definitely not holding my
breath on that one anyway guys if you
made it this far then thank you for
watching and don't forget to check out
my other video where explain the history
of the Gojo Clan and the curse
techniques of the zenin clan also I'd
appreciate if you shared and likeed this
video If you enjoyed it and until the
next one peace out